would you rather have Scottie Pippen's
life well you were talking about Pippen
and talking how he's on in the media a
lot lately talking about Jordan in
different comparisons with LeBron yes
yeah and then the topic was who
benefited more from the other Scottie
Pippen or Michael Jordan and then it was
whose career would you want everything
everything head to toe Scottie Pippen or
Charles Barkley
I could have Barclays career post
basketball and basketball yeah or would
I rather be Scottie Pippen or Charlie
I'd rather be Charles Barkley I mean I'm
I'm a hall-of-famer one of the top 50
players I didn't win any championships
but I'm winning some championships here
with my analysis I'm beloved I'm
relevant household name by the way what
Scottie Pippen say this time around that
Michael had more help than LeBron okay I
can't keep it feels like Scottie has a
maybe sky he's complimenting himself by
saying Mike had more more help yes yes
see so you would rather have a good post
basketball television career than a
handful of rings he's had a great post
basketball career Barkley he's hosted
Saturday Night Live
I mean Scottie hadn't done anything
Scottie obviously decorated who's a
better player Berkeley or Scottie Pippen
Berkeley Berkeley quite a bit yeah
that means Scotty Scotty was fortunate
he'd be played with Mike and Mike was
fortunately played with Scottie I just
I'm just surprised I think that winning
is not valued more well and especially
in that way I mean you were part of one
of the most dominant eras of basketball
let me bring in Reggie Reggie where do
you stand on it very difficult because
if you're going to embody the totality
of both careers because now you can put
in charles's post careers let's not
forget he's won a couple Emmys as well
so to me those are his Championships
don't hurt their like the six ring
Scottie has and you're right
Charles is beloved worldwide not to say
that Scottie is not Piscotty is loved
worldwide because he played with Michael
Jordan and yes six championship rings
Charles is beloved not only what he did
on the court because he was one of the
handful of top power fours and players
of his time but because of what he does
on a nightly basis on TV and what he
says and on top of this because people
don't talk about this with Charles his
generosity he is continually giving to
the inner city and making sure people
have better lives that people do not
talk about with us or Charles so having
said all that I would probably go with
Sir Charles because if you're adding
everything up I like the lifestyle of
Charles and he doesn't care Charles and
probably I'm trying to think who else
can say and do whatever they want Howard
Stern those are the only two people that
have a free license to say and do
whatever they want without any really
true repercussion wait Scottie also said
and I'm paraphrasing here that Michael
he could do less because he had more
help on his team no I mean he did play
with let me ask you a question
what other Hall of Famers has LeBron
play dress or soon to be Hall of Famers
will be Hall of Famers is Kyrie one
right oh well except in Miami Dwyane
Wade and maybe and maybe Chris but I
think Bosh is a hall-of-famer okay no he
played with two so Mike played with
obviously Scottie
Rodman so I think they're even right
that's it Hall of Famers him body played
with Scottie longer you know he had then
LeBron played with D Wade and Chris Bosh
it's very difficult Scott hey it's gotta
get six rings all time defensive player
but he played with the goes yeah you
know we look good playing with the go we
keep trying to chop this up when you
can't compare these two players we just
you know
and we trying to resume
I can look its players like you and I
because we grew up in the Jordan era and
at times it's hard for us to let that
ghost go because look I played against
them since 1987 until the time he
retired as a Washington wizard so I've
seen all the good and they're not so
good in the bad so I went through it so
it's it's difficult for me I played
versus LeBron his rookie season so I
didn't get to see what everyone is seen
now I love what I'm seeing all time
great he's on my top five if I was
starting a team he probably my small
forward as hard as it was when I told
you I had to take Larry legend off but
it's hard to compare the two because
there's different rules different eras
it's just a different time but we can't
let go of the Michael Jordan ghosts
because he was that dominating that good
for those of us like you and I who grew
up in that generation let me give you
the full introduction here Reggie Miller
Hall of Famer Turner Sports NBA analyst
he had the call last night with the
Rockets and the Warriors he'll also be
doing game for tomorrow night 9:00
Eastern on TNT why the confetti at
Golden State home games after a win a
little surprising for a two-time
champion but okay I don't know maybe the
kids like it but I don't know because
there's that good and it's a little
surprising yeah it's all about
entertainment though isn't it you know
maybe someone for the for the very first
time is going to a Warriors game and
they want and people want to see that
they want to be bathed in confetti they
want to be bathed in confetti all right
Steph Curry last night I guess it's the
tale of two halves because you guys you
and see web we're talking about he was
having open looks and he wasn't knocking
down three so what happened in the third
quarter that all of a sudden Steph Curry
is back I think Steve Kerr started to
put him like they were running him off a
lot of screens trying to get him going
and he had some wide open
in the first half I think he just
flipped the ball in his hands and they
went to that high screen and roll where
he got the switch he wanted and it
started in a third quarter with a couple
drives he saw the n1 with the left hand
steve nash allah and i think that kind
of got his rhythm going and in that
first three that he made from like 28 29
feet where there was a breakdown
defensively by the rockets and then the
floodgates were open and as you know
because you're a former shooter and
score it only takes a couple times for
the ball to go through for a shooter to
you know revert back to his mechanics
and to go 7 for 7 in that third quarter
with a different variety of shots to me
now Houston they had a problem before
but now that curry and let's see if he
can back it up with the game for
performance like Game three the
floodgates are open now because he's
found his mojo and we already saw what
Durant did the first two games and at 25
last night but now if you add curry to
the mix this team is untouchable once
they get it clicking like that got an
idea for you for Turner Sports can we
get hades mom can we get draymond greens
mom and maybe a couple moms from the
Rockets and it's just mom TV like the
the real moms of the NBA and it's a
second screen and then we can listen to
them maybe some beverages in there yeah
right get some liquid get some liquid
courage going dream ons night how great
would that be
yeah and we'd be good right now but do
you understand if you understand the
personalities of the mom you can
understand the personalities of the
players on the court because a lot of
times they're one in the same
because Dre mom's mom is very outspoken
very articulate and understands the
point she wants to get across very much
the same way her son does that would be
a fascinating show because I think they
would be brutally honest kind of like
how they're their sons are I think it'd
be I think it'd be great
just call it NBA moms and then you could
be Andy Cohen like you'd be that you
could be the moderator there but
drayman's mom doesn't play though man
she's cereal I know I know
can she be objective was your mom
objective she was but she also let me
know when I was in the wrong and I think
she lets draymond Green know behind
closed doors if he's wrong I don't think
she would publicly say he's ever wrong
but I think behind closed doors just
like Steph's mom that's wrong let him
know what he said after that one
hey we're not about that came out and
apologized but in I liked it because
most people think that Steph is a choir
boy and you don't become the league
two-time MVP by being a choir boy yes
it's nice it is good in itself but Steph
has a mean streak you just never see it
and I think it kind of showed the
frustration of the shooting and the
series and maybe trickle down because of
the injuries and not being fully 100%
even though he says he's 100% you can
tell by his movement that he's not a
hundred percent I think that all came
out on that play now he'll go back to
being the choir boy and you won't hear
any more profanity but from a personal
standpoint I think it was needed for
that team at that particular moment I
just I was curious where remember
Houston was isoing staff or they they
would have a pick-and-roll and they were
just begging for staff to come over and
guard Harden and all he was too getting
tired on the defensive it where did all
that stuff go because we look for
excuses as to why Golden State you know
got blown out with the Rockets and Steph
Curry wasn't playing well where last
night that didn't seem to matter well
it's funny because even if you go to
Game two and the blowout on the switches
with Steph they would score but they
were scoring every time and we counted
the first five plays of the game last
night they went at Steph Curry yeah that
was their point and I think that's going
to continue
but let's flip it they're going at James
Harden as well he's just as bad
defensively as they're saying deaf
Korea's and when you saw that in the
third quarter Steph Curry made it a
mission to go at James Harden to make
him work at the defensive end so I think
each team is taking a page out of their
own playbook but who's the worst
offender reg staff or harden Harden is
it because somebody won't maybe a
combination of both at least Steph is
attempting there's at times when harden
just lets the defender go right by him
and he does the old bull away and just
and it is not other than capela who is a
great shot blocker at least the defense
behind Steph you've got dream on and
you've got KD who's a pretty good shot
blocker and you've got klay Thompson
who's a pretty good on-ball defender so
I think there's more defenders
surrounding Steph and there is James
Harden but between the two James Harden
is it's the worst defender who's more
likely to win a regular season MVP Steph
Curry or LeBron James LeBron James
because KD is there with Stephanie's not
going to get that the same credit that
will always they will always take votes
away because you have to the three two
of the top five players in the league on
one team you look with LeBron James join
with that unit and and you just got to
applaud but this team isn't worse than
the one he took to the finals when they
played San Antonio first time he went
there that that was pretty bad that was
not a good team Big Z in the middle and
man oh my god
well boobie had a couple of good games
but man that was not a good team at all
and they went to the finals but it
wasn't another all-star on that team
history of Kevin Love who's a perennial
all-star yeah in this team and he's got
Tristan Thompson no no
no no some reason you don't like Tristan
Thompson every time I bring his name up
you were quick to jump on Tristan
Thompson he averages my Reggie he gives
me five and a half and what three or
four no it's the energy you need players
like don't you think that's what he's
seven reg he's averaging six and four
Chloe could give me better numbers than
Tristan no I got the girls are on my
side now with the kardashians man
they're on my side are you any problem
with Steph with the shimmy no not at all
the profanity the shimmy everything that
happened last night for Steph as we seen
at times a little bit out of character
what was needed for that game do you
think that before before I know but did
you like you needed it didn't you like
you what you were you were so amped up
you weren't afraid to express I like
that yeah robots
I like that from stuff it's an it was
unexpected do you see in the first half
when he was missing the reason the body
language yeah we're like what look
all the planets are now back to being
aligned because of his game last night
and that's why I believe Houston is in
serious trouble now because they've let
him find his mojo that's the last thing
they did a good job of keeping pressure
on him keeping him off-balance and they
had a shot now let's see if he can
follow up his game three performance in
Game four he doesn't have to have 30 but
he missed in that first half literally
four wide-open threes I mean he was
looking at a 40-point game easily yeah I
was
I was really surprised like you and
c-webb we're both surprises like those
are those are openly those are like clay
Thompson looks and he was not making him
but give him a lot of credit because
steph has set the bar that high we
expect when he's wide open
i mean it for it to be a layup right
because he set the bar that high because
of his shooting reg will be on the call
tomorrow night it'll be game for 9:00
Eastern on TNT reg did you are you
staying in the Bay Area we're staying in
the Bay Area baby nice nice
I behaved over here tell Cyr we settle
oh and mark absolutely
thank you interested let low and david
aldridge horse we love you Theodore
thank you Rick for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]